hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in 2019 apple could be having another
2005 moment like the iPod in 2005 the
iPhone
seems to be running out of steam can
Apple make a stellar update to their
device and make sales blast-off again or
is it time for a completely new category
of device altogether in this video we'll
take a look at what's going on with the
company and what they plan to do in 2005
the iPod Apple's best seller was running
out of steam to make things worse mobile
phones were just becoming capable of mp3
playback this was a threat and Apple
needed something to get themselves ahead
in 2007 Steve Jobs stepped out on stage
at Macworld he pulled out the first-ever
iPhone to a receptive crowd Steve later
put his finger on the screen and
scrolled and people cheered in amazement
as if he was a time travel how do I do
this I just take my finger and I school
this is what Apple was best at they had
once revolutionized the personal
computer industry and have now done the
same for the mobile phone for a long
time and for a lot of people Apple was
by far the best and still maybe
depending on who you ask
however a decade after in valuing the
iPhone their biggest profit maker the
smartphone market is starting to change
competitors such as Samsung Google and
Huawei have started closing the gap and
this isn't to mention new players such
as Xiaomi and Oppo which are nobodies
just a few years ago meanwhile Apple's
laptops of HP Lenovo and Dell to contend
with Apple seems to be losing ground on
both sides the world is changing
technological ability and performance
are becoming simply good enough for most
people regardless of the brand name
sluggish iPhone sales are Apple's
biggest worry historically more than
half of apples revenue came from the
iPhone in 2015 this was around 66% of
revenue but now despite having higher
prices iPhones only account for about
50% of total revenue investors smell
trouble and Apple share prices fall on
35% since his peak last year but in
saying this some of the factors are
outside the company's control the whole
market has generally been down since
this period and slow iPhone sales in
China due to a slowing economy and a
trade war with the eastern nation also
contribute in reaction Apple has
reportedly cut iPhone production by 10
percent for the first quarter of 2019 so
the question remains is there more to
the story well for many consumers the
price they're paying for what they're
getting is just too high the halo effect
where a loyal customer base is willing
to pay a premium for Apple as they have
always done in the past could be wearing
off the iPhones iOS software along with
a tight ecosystem might be the only
thing holding up sales for now so this
next point is pretty important and just
show us how the world has actually
changed basically the smartphone market
is at saturation everyone who wants a
phone has one it's the natural
progression of the maturing industry
it isn't just Apple facing these issues
though the global smartphone market has
been decimated lately from 40 percent
growth in 2013 to a slight contraction
of about point two to 0.3 percent over
the last two years respectively so why
exactly are global sales slowing it
could be that the global macroeconomic
situation is weakening and then there's
stagnation in innovation who wants to
get rid of a perfectly good phone for a
new one that does basically the same
thing the bottom line is that people
aren't buying right now in November of
2018 Apple announced it will no longer
give the data for sales of US devices
[Music]
so it's clear that Apple needs to do
something
one thing that they could do is what
they used to do best innovate so where
are the new products and where's the
innovation now price increases planned
obsolescence and incremental refreshes
aren't cutting it so apple's cash cow
may be drying up when the company may be
increasingly looking to the services
sector to pick up the slack and we'll
get to that in a little bit but the more
I thought about the situation the more I
thought that Apple could have something
up their sleeve here's what I suspect
there might be a breakthrough on the
hardware side yes there could be
augmented reality glasses but something
else might be coming something actually
more gradual now this is me just
thinking but the 2018 iPad pro strikes
me it could be a shining light and a
glimpse into a new direction for Apple
hardware wires this iteration of the
iPad pro was a missed opportunity
because of software was still basic but
its performance out shown the 2017
MacBook Pro and is on par with the i7
macbook pro of the same year this is
amazing for a mobile chip but the main
point here is that the a 12 X Bionic
chip that powers the iPad pro was
designed by Apple even more important is
that this chip was based on ARM
architecture arm is the type of chip
architecture used in mobile phones
desktop PCs in contrast to use x86
architecture chips like Intel ARM chips
use less power and have traditionally
been seen as a weak platform for
demanding uses but in 2019 this is
changing since the x86 instruction set
basically the built-in code that tells
the chip how to operate is bloated and
inefficient compared to arm and the
others new talk of arm being a pathway
to the future of computing even some
server farms have started using arm
chips to save power adobe has converted
the full version of Photoshop to ARM
processors to run on the iPad and
likewise Adobe Premiere Pro it can now
edit 4k video natively on an iPad pro
with ease Qualcomm has also announced a
new chip designed from the ground up for
PCs running full versions of Windows
this is desktop class performance and
function on a mobile chip for the first
in their own time Apple might decide to
create a full Mac OS iPad and put their
powerful custom chips to good use in the
coming years as I was thinking about
this even more I went through Apple's
recent acquisition history and found out
that they recently purchased a UK chip
manufacturer dialog semiconductor for
600 million dollars apple also announced
that they will completely design their
own in-house graphics chips by 2020 so
what I'm basically trying to say is that
the new mobile chips from Apple may just
be a dark horse that shocks everyone
maybe even future MacBooks could run
armed thanks to its lean instruction set
many longtime subscribers would know
that I've been predicting desktop-class
mobile chips since 2013 so seeing such
an event come true would be very
exciting for me so making a full Mac OS
iPad that's modified for touch could eat
into macbook sales but there could still
be a case for it so everyone has an
iphone already but a laptop class tablet
is still very rare there's a gap in the
market there and if Apple could work
their magic to produce a two-in-one
convertible with the power to blow
everyone else out of the water that's a
great opportunity and if Apple could do
it without being criminally overpriced
it could get people excited for the
Apple brand again and I'd argue that
that's something that they need right
now
so Apple could innovate or they could do
what they said they're going to do and
that is expand on services in my
previous Apple video I mentioned that
Tim Cook knew that I phone sales were
going too slow he stated that the
company will now be focused on services
this year iTunes will allow streaming on
Samsung's TVs and other competitor
devices will support airplane until
recently these streaming features are
restricted to Apple TV Tim Cook has also
stated that the company is going to be
launching new services this year it's
rumored that the new services could be
something like a Netflix streaming
service but based off Apple TV content
Apple has also collaborated with Amazon
to allow Alexa to control Apple music so
Apple is opening up more and they need
to we can just look at history allowing
their services to be used across
different devices has historically been
successful for Apple most people forget
that the original iPod almost flopped
because iTunes was Mac only it was only
after iTunes release on Windows that the
iPod took off and iTunes became the top
digital music store in the world Apple
has also recently bought Shazam
highlighting their interest in
entertainment systems remember the iPod
Touch will there's a possibility that
Apple may be re-releasing it after a
3-year hiatus it's actually a good
entry-level strategy to get new people
into the iOS ecosystem in summary Apple
is facing tough competition in the
smartphone market the biggest revenue
driver it's a market that has pretty
much reached saturation and the end of
its initial life cycle many competitors
provide cheaper alternatives that are
not noticeably inferior to iPhones so
extrapolating what happens in five to
ten years time if Apple stays stagnant
for example what if a company makes a
great foldable phone that's powerful
cheap but actually Pleasant and
convenient to use maybe that's a wild
idea but the point I'm trying to make is
that Apple needs to figure out how to
top the unexpected innovation in the
past half we'll figure out a way to make
a better photo bull phone that works
like magic but what that happen now
Tim Cook does believe that Apple's
foundations and ecosystem are azzolini
enough to withstand the current downturn
and I kind of agree now I have to make
this point very clear Apple has a lot of
cash so they're not going anywhere
anytime soon
but I am noticing a trend and I have
been commenting about Apple losing its
magic for years I did make a video in
2016 talking about this I could see the
trend and now it's starting to come to
life maybe in the future
Apple mostly be a services and software
company who knows
Apple has proven time and time again to
be a market leader and innovator this is
the company that brought the Mac iPod
iPhone iPad and revolutionized how we
interact and see our devices even if you
prefer their competitors devices their
presence is undeniable Steve Jobs and
the team he led created something
special and something that lives in his
memory so if anyone can turn this around
its Apple but can they do that without
Steve Tim Cook was handpicked by Steve
Jobs so maybe they can what do you guys
think the future of Apple is going to be
stagnation innovation or a majority
services and software company let me
know what you think in the comments
section below anyway that was our look
at Apple and this has been - go go
you've been watching cold fusion thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more interesting topics
about our world you should consider
subscribing
all right I'll catch you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one
cohesion is he thinking
[Music]
[Applause]